Jimmy Kimmel breaks down in tears over
the mass shooting in his hometown of Las
Vegas this is just a regular part of our
lives now during Monday's Jimmy Kimmel
Live monologue the late-night host was
visibly distraught over the tragic
shooting that left 59 dead and over 500
injured at the route 91 Country Music
Festival on Sunday here we are again in
the aftermath of another terrible
inexplicable shocking and painful
tragedy this time in Las Vegas which
happens to be my hometown this morning
we have children without parents and
fathers without sons and mothers without
daughters we lost two police officers we
lost a nurse Jimmy also addressed gun
control in the need for Americans to
stand up and make a change it's a public
safety issue and something needs to be
done already so tell your Congress
people to do something I mean it's not
enough to send your love and prayers who
do we send our love and support and
whatever else is needed to Las Vegas and
the families from all over the country
later country singer Luke combs who
performed at route 91 prior to the
attack took the Jimmy Kimmel live stage
to honor the Las Vegas victims
[Music]
still be